freunde es ist schön wieder da zu sein
ich hoffe ihr freut euch auch wenn ich
für euch nicht weg war ich war nämlich
im urlaub und ich werde heute mal wieder
einen tag lang essen bestellen bzw bei
drei verschiedenen spots essen bestellen
nicht wie beim letzten mal das teuerste
sondern heute das günstigste ich freue
mich darauf denn ich bin fest überzeugt
dass es überhaupt nichts über die
qualität aus sagt das ist quasi der
gleiche aufbau wie beim letzten mal als
wir das ganze mit dem teuersten gemacht
haben wie das kreuz einfach mal blind
sind hoch und
burger brater ist anscheinend einen
kölner bürger sporty mich noch gar nicht
kenne es sieht gar nicht mehr so viel
spaß dass ich hier mal bilder dabei
erstklassig coburger tomatenscheiben
snack gurken burger brater soße kostet 8
euro 40 und ich würde bei einer davon
ausgehen dass das auch der günstigste
italien raps ist das günstigste ja
650 zu beilagen fingerfood und so was
sehen wir mal nicht mit rein das heißt
es wird dann doch für mich der zigarette
wird sagen bestellen und dann gucken wir
direkt zum nächsten restaurant wir
machen ja wieder drei restaurants an der
zahl das heißt es wird zeit für die
nummer 2 und wir starten direkt eine
frau immer schlimm runter
runter
jetzt haben wir das zita mexikaner
chips und overclocker sind die
vorspeisen bei den vorspeisen gucke ich
jetzt einfach mal gar nicht erst dann
haben wir eine endlager mixa für neun
euro 50 ok hauptgerichte cassidy als
sieben euro neunzigsten minute extras
das heißt es wird claudia werden ich
habe auch bisher gute sachen auf jeden
fall statt viel plastik auf jeden fall
ein rap und die jetzt eine füllung okay
ich kann mir nicht alles aufnehmen weil
manche kosten halt werden nämlich pastor
wahrscheinlich abgeliefert weiter geht
es mit dem dritten restaurant ich bin
gespannt was wir jetzt bekommen das sind
ja beide sind so kleine speisen ich
hatte bob 1 wo es nur große sachen gibt
wo ich einfach das system drittel und
trotzdem was meistens bekomme aber ich
überlasse das ganze wieder dem zufall
ein bisschen hier ein bisschen
herunter
und wir haben ich habe meinen finger
okay jetzt ist die frage ich hatte
meinen finger zwischen zwei restaurants
einmal lesen das sind manche türkische
mahnte was sehr geil ist und kritik
highstreet gut da ich mir es aussuchen
weil ich war genau dazwischen wofür
wärst du ich würde wahrscheinlich man
talent ich hatte ein bisschen mehr bei
den landwirten hier wird es uns relativ
einfach gemacht wir haben warnte
wintermantel und vegane manche dazu gibt
es bei lagen nachtisch das war's für das
angenehm einfach mal die gegangen
habe ich auch und hast du überhaupt das
ja ja so knoblauch ok alles andere
kostet extra und damit ist auch beim
dritten restaurant bestellt darauf freue
ich mich fast am meisten leider muss der
ob am längsten warten aber wir fangen
erst mal an mit unserem ticker los
geht's mit unserem raps sechs euro 50
haben wir das gute stück erst mal ein
stabiler april man muss dazu sagen 56
ich bezweifle dass er mich komplett satt
machen würde aber dazu kommt auch noch
dass man eigentlich ja immer noch
irgendwelche fanartikel für
mindestbestellwerte stellen muss lassen
wir heute außen vor wenn ich überlege
ich muss jetzt erst mal probieren und zu
checken aus das wäre aber sogar
vergleich finde ich wäre reaktionen
lahmacun eigentlich jahrelang oder auf
der straße holt für sechs euro
mittlerweile wird ja auch alles teurer
also schon vergleichbar bei der ist dann
noch mal eine ecke größer probieren aber
das ganze mal der preis rechtfertigt
sich an erster stelle durch den
geschmack
erstens ist hin trocken
glaube ist die zum großen teil daran
dass da oben wirklich nur tote aber es
sieht nicht verkehrt aus plaste fried
chicken drin frage jetzt denkst du dass
es die selfmade oder ist es so
100% statement das ticket für den
versuch palette also ob eingekauft oder
nichts duell aircraft ich finde man
merkt auf jeden fall dass das ein rap
von im bürgerladen ist bei der nicht
unbedingt so gesund schmeckt so der hat
so eine chance drin das frittierte
schicken und so dass direkt auf jeden
fall auch dazu bei aber es ist auf jeden
fall kann man sich die ganze bühne
aufgebaut ist bisschen unser bisschen
tomate viel schicken und da hat ein
bisschen von dieser special songs die
wir ja auch sehen also ich muss sagen
dass ein leckerer rap wenn man jetzt
aber auch das budget guckt nicht um gehe
ich irgendwie eine zelle zu machen
sondern wenn man unbedingt sein wird
weiß ich nicht weil man kriegt ja wenn
man aufs budget kriegt man glaube ich
wenn man nicht bestellt schon mal
grundsätzlich mehr für sein geld wenn
man selbst kocht sowieso wehren uns ein
euro für einen tag auch mal auch
funktioniert ich würde mal sagen
grundsolide das ist lecker dass anna
loos das ist
das einzige was dieser ist es halt so
dass crispy chicken das ist ja das ist
ein bisschen trocken keine überraschung
10 von 10 10 von 10 und auch keine tasse
überraschung habe gerade einmal
nachlesen hähnchenbrust für die frisch
mariniert und paniert das ist schon das
gebäck software sie dass sie sich die
mühe machen schauen wir was wir als
nächstes weiter geht es mit der kita die
ja für sieben euro 90 da sind wir schon
mal ein euro 40 über dem preis von
gerade eben hoffentlich lohnt sich der
aufpreis es ist alte hilfsarbeiter hoch
das ist nix höchste zeit also ich hätte
gerne jetzt eine vage hier leider noch
nicht meine küche aber unter 200 auf
jeden fall es sieht aber dafür muss man
sagen verkehrt aus wir machen einmal auf
doch kommen so wirkt irgendwie nicht
mehr ganz so leicht es wirkt sehr sehr
saftig dem feld
ich bin ready meine erwartungen kann
sich gerade nach dem aufklappen
verdoppelt habe der frauen aber dass sie
wirklich sehr sehr gut aus einer
new york crazy saftig richtig schöne
gehört also richtig schöne würzige note
wird der käse ist auch am start man
sieht das jetzt hier da sah ich ein
bisschen dadurch dass die den quasi auf
so einem fall plant wahrscheinlich
einmal komplett durch gegrillt haben
dann den kita dir drauf gegeben da habe
ich es wahrscheinlich einmal gedreht
gefüllt und das wiso einen chip aus käse
und schmeckt richtig gut meint
dann sieht man so richtig song crazy das
recht 37 das ist tue das ist übelst viel
dafür so das ist dann also wenn wir
jetzt gerade schon gemeckert haben das
ist ja nur zum player zum sattwerden
zwei davon wahrscheinlich wobei die
schon mächtig sind muss man auch sagen
weil ich hätte nicht gedacht dass es so
gut isst du musst jetzt sehe ich darf
man auch ein bisschen können das richtig
lecker
keine das sogar gewürz für mich war der
start so richtig rein und erst so
richtig so danach legst du dich schlafen
du hast du drei bier getrunken dann isst
du den devisen zu verschwunden es gab
nicht mehr er hat das alles auch gerade
wenn du gehst nach dem 3 4 von hat der
die gewichte so was braucht man alter
das ding ist halt auch gerade haben wir
so ein bisschen waren wir so ein
bisschen stur c coupé 56 für diesen raum
aber das schmeckt halt so gut dass so
die 750 vergisst aber man muss einfach
sagen essen bestellen ist teuer so wenn
das die günstigen hauptspeisen sind so
in mexiko kostet also 3 euro diese
elemente wie gut hier direkt wieder dass
ein paket man denkt so wenn man denkt es
könnte ein bisschen wenig sein aber das
ist so 400 gramm da stehst du erst mal
egal meinte mit knoblauchsoße überkommt
mich vegetarisch streng genommen nicht
gegangen ist wir haben aber das sieht
super aus man muss dazu sagen warnt er
kennt ja vielleicht nicht jeder gibt es
ja wirklich in allen kulturen dieser
diese diese kleinen teigtaschen ob es
jetzt tiroler sind oder mantel sind wir
auch immer oder maultaschen aber so oder
so es wirklich eigentlich immer deshalb
bin ich gespannt wie diese ausführungen
hier schneck joghurt nur wird nur wird
gehört
[Musik]
wenn man es mit nudeln vergleicht man
nun will man erwarten dass diese sich
als ente sind auch so ein bisschen
weshalb die mantel verteilen so richtig
kraft ich muss sagen die manche selbst
geben vor allem textur der geschmack
kommt vor allem von der knoblauchsoße
wirklich einfach spaß zu essen ich habe
auch das gefühl dass jemand auch von
hand gemacht sind den laden macht nur
man könne ja also es ist auf jeden fall
eine wilde sache wird würde ich auf
jeden fall weiterführen würde ich auch
sofort wieder im stern für acht euro
wirst dafür ist eine vollwertige
mahlzeit verachtung dafür ist das ultra
stabil das fühlt sich auch gar nicht
zueinander nach so platz sein also wenn
du es jetzt einordnen müsstest number
one pass tor
nummer zwei man muss auch mit
einbeziehen wie viel geld und so wollten
mich trotzdem auf die matte gehen und
trotzdem sehr sehr lecker und vor allen
dingen das günstigste heute gewesen der
rap auf den dritten platz alle drei
sachen aber wirklich beim besten willen
nicht schlecht oder wurden nicht
enttäuscht überhaupt nicht enttäuscht
die käser die art komplett over
delivered war viel krasser als gedacht
hier wusste ich irgendwie schon dass es
geil sein würde und wurde auch nicht
enttäuscht wir ab sofort eine gute
entscheidung einfach mal neue sachen
auszuprobieren und sich die
verrücktesten wege zu überlegen um
irgendwelche sachen zum ersten mal zu
bestellen macht es auch und dank fürs zu
sehen ist nichts video parat